So, let's see if we can figure out the disk access time. Suppose we have a disk
that has a 1000 cylinders and 10 sectors
per track. Suppose that the head assemble starts out
at cylinder 0, at one end of the
disk, and the cylinders are of course numbered 0
through 999. Suppose that the speed at which the
head assembly can move is 10 microseconds per cylinder.
So it's moving at linear speed. And the
disk rotates 100 times per second. Suppose we have
a perfect controller in the bus, or very, very
fast relative to this. And suppose that there is
no previous request so we don't have to
worry about queuing. So the question for you is
what is the average time to read a randomly
chosen byte from this disk, where every bite on
the disc has the same chance of being requested?